would you sleep or did you take most of
your inspiration from when you decided
to create this big baby scumbag brand
that you created where did you take most
your inspiration from oh man
honestly this goes back to me just being
a kid and like just like make pretending
I had my own brand of [ __ ] and like you
know saying just kind of going back to
like being in like the third grade
fourth grade and like playing yugioh
cards and she I had to put the dragon on
it you don't say anything like that uh
the logo is it's a play off of like
those trucker logos like a Mack logo you
know Sam wears like the Bulldog circle
around it with Mack you know I'm saying
a lot of this should I put out is just
the influence of [ __ ] that I [ __ ] when
I was younger like the skateboards for
instance like a lot of a lot of the
skateboards and should just trucker hats
the trucker hats I was influenced by any
idea why for I was wearing the trucker
hats with the with the brain NER D brain
logo on it you know saying I want to I
want to make hockey jerseys do it I was
born I was wearing so many hockey
jerseys back in high school man a guy
had a [ __ ] collection of them and you
got all like that NASCAR stuff - yeah
yeah oh yeah that's really big on you
like a dude with NASCAR it was kind of a
thing like I was always going to the
thrift store and [ __ ] and like you know
us like being out here in Florida like
it was like NASCAR capital yeah so so at
the gas stations yeah like it's
everywhere so it's right next to the
butterfly knives it's inevitable bro so
like III became a NASCAR fan without
even realizing it because I was getting
I was behind these shirts just because
they look cool I was like damn like
these shirts are fire and [ __ ] and then
like I must say around like 2014 one of
my homies black cray at that at that
time I wasn't even rapping I wasn't even
rapping yet but black Cray had put out
a song called Daytona 500 here put out -
here I put out a handful of songs that
was like NASCAR reference you know I'm
saying and like I was like damn you know
just [ __ ] is tight like you know saying
somebody else's into this NASCAR [ __ ] -
like I am you know I'm saying let alone
like somebody that I really [ __ ] with
musically so it just feel the flame of
fire like I'm gonna take I'm gonna take
the NASCAR [ __ ] somewhere for real yeah
it's kind of like your your music is
like a crossover of meme culture you
know they mean for show for show like my
music is my music is a product of my
everyday thoughts what I watch on TV
movies video games pop culture cartoons
lifestyle all that [ __ ] man yeah all
that [ __ ] in one like in one [ __ ]
boiling pot and I stir it up and you
know I'm saying like all of my songs is
just like there's this is like this is a
you know I'm saying Avilan tomorrowworld
my girl will tell you like tiger king
like when I came out like I was I was
strictly tiger I didn't want to watch
nothing else but tiger yeah yeah yeah
you gotta finish it before you start
something I know so write out 5 times I
was like yo cuz was so crazy about that
[ __ ] do is like I didn't know like so I
knew about Big Cat Rescue I used to live
like 10 minutes from big head but like I
never knew like all that [ __ ] was
happening it's not crazy you know I'm
saying so I was like dude like I gotta
make a song about joy right like what
that's the craziest thing about like
around here this area I mean Florida in
general but this area for sure there's
like so many things like that like big
cat rescue you live there forever you
always throw past em you never knew that
crazy story behind it never knew about
Carroll Baskin and just that host and
what's crazy dude is that there's a
there's kind of like a theory
and you know there's this one there's
this one scene on Tiger king and Carroll
Baskin is talking about walking down
Nebraska Avenue yeah now anybody
familiar with Tampa knows what Nebraska
Avenue is you know cuz he described
Nebraska yeah what is Nebraska Nebraska
Avenue is just very sketchy it's a very
sketchy Street you know it's where a lot
of you know prostitution goes down you
know I'm saying
so in tiger Cain Carroll Baskin she had
said yeah like I'm walking down Nebraska
to clear my head this Annette and her
husband well he wasn't her husband at
that time but Dan he was driving down
that Street and just picked her up right
told her to hop in you know I'm saying
Dan's a millionaire and he gave her a
gun you know I'm saying so you know a I
don't know man but it was doomed from
the start
Baskin a Carroll Bascom might have been
a prostitute she very well could have
been what are your feelings on Carroll
basket now that some time has passed you
maybe had some time to reflect do you
still feel the way that you did and your
song and she did it she did it she
really she did cuz was so crazy is like
dude like a lot of that she just doesn't
add up but then I did not one thing one
thing that is kind of weird though is
like when a dance friends was on the
show and his friend was saying that like
the day before he disappeared dan was
like yo like if I can pull this off this
will be the slickest thing I've ever
done in my life
it was like I think here's how I look at
it if he was the kind of dude who's
gonna drive down Nebraska pick up some
[ __ ] and give her a gun and say point
this at me I need someone to talk to
you're the same kind of dude who's gonna
take off to Costa Rica yeah and you're
gonna be you know living with a new
hooker every got a whole new name that
was it in America when you could still
just disappear yourself there's no bones
you could still pay for with cash for
everything you didn't need credit card
I paid people off along the way he's
living large she's got he's living in a
house with like 14 underage girls in
Costa Rica buncha Tigers but see that's
that's the that's the crazy part man
because Kyle Baskin was doing a lot of
sketchy [ __ ] man so it's like mm-hmm no
man and then even even Dan's family was
saying how like Carroll basically like
threatened to cut them off you know I'm
saying like if they yeah yeah if they
talk to the media and you know yeah
that's a weird conspiracy so I don't
know what the latest is on that latest
develop it just seems too obvious it
just seems way too obvious
further love loving the Lions like come
on or Tigers like what was crazy about
Big Cat Rescue too is like dude like
it's it's you know being from Tampa like
you know [ __ ] is like literally right in
front of your face like dude I was at
Publix
the other day and there was two people
there that had big cat rescue volunteer
shirts on why you don't say what color
they were red okay what is that level I
think that's newbie level noobs
yeah free Joe what's his what's up with
him didn't you get the corona virus
disappeared he did I mean I think he's
hope you know I hope so you know what
honestly if y'all go to his Instagram
you got a boy his husband right yeah
yeah oh like their poster like memes of
like the what's what's the dude's name
that took over the park oh oh yeah I
forgot his name I forgot but they're
posting memes of him they're trying to
like blackmail him now you know they
trying to take their doing like the same
smear campaign they were doing for yeah
yeah yeah daughter tried to take him
down so Joe exotics whole Instagram is
just like yeah like he
he's doing shady [ __ ] like he needs to
be in jail to that I thought he's gonna
get pardoned for a second by Trump yeah
really yeah I thought so
what's crazy is like he doesn't have
been I don't think he has bail cuz I
looked up his network doing Jatakas is
he really that bhop money to be flipping
those kinda old Tigers I live in Tiger
history I don't think he got there I
think he got to do that harm or
something brokers yeah something's
[ __ ] up with that whole situation
doesn't add up
no I definitely doesn't add up amen
free Joe exotic
[Laughter]